to be honest state premier of the region
of zarland
in western germany germany has now
gone beyond the one million infected
people corona infected people
you were part of the negotiations with
angela merkel and the other
regional leaders where you discussed
extended and intensified the existing
corona measures just this week some
people are already saying
they're not hard enough are they right
i don't think so the the thing is that
we
tried hard to stay ahead of the curve
from the beginning
of the pandemic and i'm sure that we can
flatten the curve with the measures we
have now taken
and our goal is that from december to
23rd on
we can lift those measures those
restrictions
because we wanted people to have a
family christmas even this year
okay but what if that leads to another
third wave potentially i mean how do you
how do you foresee that the goal is to
bring
the numbers down before december the
23rd
and we're also offering the people
extended testing capacities so
they can test themselves if they're
showing symptoms of
covid and that makes me very optimistic
and that we can handle that before
december the 23rd and
compared to other countries in europe
and in the world
i mean we're still seeing all-time highs
here in germany
but the numbers are lower than in other
countries and that makes
me very optimistic we can handle it so
you're a regular member of the meetings
between
angela merkel and the other regional
leaders you've been there from the start
as you're the state leader of zaland how
has the mood changed in those meetings
over the
last few months it has changed a lot
from the beginning of the pandemic
i remember that when we came into this
pandemic
my federal state of scotland was hit
hard by
covet because of our border situation to
france which was also hit hard
and it has changed now because
in the beginning of the pandemic the
states in the eastern parts of germany
were not that concerned about covet
in that time and that has changed now as
germany well has a high rate of
covert patients now over all federal
states and the situation in hospitals
across germany has changed a lot to the
worse
and this has changed the mood definitely
so you've been a close
observer of angela merkel over the last
few months as well you've seen her act
in a crisis
her era is going to come to an end next
year with a federal election she's not
going to run again that's what she's
announced already what are you going to
miss
well angela merkel is a great leader and
she's experienced but she's still
ahead of many others
in our country and
i think she has preserved her
capability of discussing things
that that is something very rarely found
among world leaders that have been in
office for such a long time
and i really appreciate that capability
of hers and i will miss that
and as a last question a private
question which is also a political one
this year how are you going to spend
christmas
we will have a very private family
christmas this year
my wife and i were expecting our third
child and we're looking forward to dad
and
my my utmost goal is to keep the family
safe and that is why we won't meet up
with too many people
and i really suggest that to all the
others
keep it safe keep it private that will
help us to flatten the curve
to be a sons regional leader of zahlan
thank you very much
thank you it's been a pleasure
you